and another very specific moment about
polonium it need to be fresh prepared
because every moment it became half
harmful harmful
polonium has to be fresh made it was
taking again from reactor
brought to london
and used against
my husband alexander
[Music]
so once you've been granted the once you
received all the documents in the uk
what was alexander doing
of course sasha was not the ordinary
person and
he worked against organized crime since
i believe 2002 2003 when russian money
just flowed to europe to uk
and it was very difficult to understand
sometimes what this money came from was
it just real business what is the crime
money and sasha became practically very
useful to explain where this money came
from
connection between
people from russian government to
people in organized crime you can say
real gangsters
and
they accepted his consulting
and then it was a serious job doing in
spain just before 2006 he receives his
offer to work for spanish authorities
against
organized crime from russia
can you walk us through the events that
happened on that day on the 1st of
november everything was fine during the
evening
but
when it was a midnight
he suddenly became sick
and
it's never stopped after that
he couldn't breathe
and his
temperature was very low
when he was in hospital and it was a lot
of tests
and x-ray everything and i asked if i
could take him back home they said
probably yes
but in few hours after all testing they
said no we better to keep him here
and
just
go home and you can visit him next day
they found his immune system dropped
almost to zero
and they decided this was a side effect
of antibiotics
and they didn't know why
and only when in 10 days he started to
develop all signs of radioactive
illness
he could not eat
he hardly could drink because it was
quite painful but he stayed in a general
like practice he was not isolated
and it was almost 10 days
he said to doctors uh could you check me
for poisoning from very beginning
because
i'm
i have a political son i was
i escaped from russia i did work from
russian security service
i i'm having very powerful enemies for
what he said i tried to be patient for
all these 10 days but in 10 days i said
anybody could tell me what happened to
my husband
they called different doctors from
different units and one said he's
definitely look as my patient he was
from cancer unit and when they tried to
check him for other activities
they couldn't they couldn't find
nothing
but he was taken to another unit
and they sent his
blood
examples for another test
and when they first time realized he was
poisoned
what did he talk about in those days to
you
we talk a lot
about
when he
left hospital what we're going to do
we try to talk about future
and because he couldn't eat
and his dream again was when he will
return back home i will buy him
pineapple
and i will cut it to small pieces and
i'll put it to fridge and he will eat it
cold pieces and just enjoy it you know
we just try to talk about very
normal stuff
but since then sasha's health became
worse and worse like us every day i
could see him every day became
all weak or difficult to talk
but he still had three days to talk to
police
it means police had all statements from
sasha
when he
said about his meetings
where he went
how he did it
and
sasha was professional and he knew what
exactly you should say
to help to investigate this case it
means
as a person who was murdered
investigated his own case
do you remember what was the last thing
he told you
day before he was very weak but he
it was not more uh
interview with police
and again he said just a few words
and when i was ready to go home i said
sasha i just go
home because anatoly is waiting for me
but tomorrow morning i'll be here and i
will be with you
and he just
told me marina i love you
when i came back home
and almost
on midnight i received call from police
who told me marina we should talk to you
i said now
at midnight
after you just
you know what happened
and they said no we insist we have to
talk to you and when they arrived they
explained to me is this radioactive
material it's polonium-210
they never ever had another practice
this kind of murder weapon
in terms of polonium who actually has
access to it it's not like regular
people could could get polonium in their
hands polonium-210
is a radioactive material
you could find only in an atomic
station or
reactor and to
those and those what was used
for sasha it was a very big amount
and another very specific moment about
polonium it need to be fresh prepared
because every moment it became half
harmful harmful
polonium has to be fresh made it was
taken again
from reactor
brought to london
and used against
my husband alexander
what happened after that to you and your
son what did you have to do
it was difficult for anatoly to decide
to go to school straight after but and
he couldn't go straight after because he
should be checked
or we poisoned polonium or
again
how it might affected people around you
i was waiting for test results for three
days
it was the most difficult time for me
because um
if it's something bad and i will die not
maybe like sasha but quite soon
and anatoly who was 12 years old
what is happening to him
and when i met people from health
protection agency saying to me marina
you have trace of polonium
it's quite uh noticeable but it's not
you're not going to die now
it might increase uh a level of getting
cancer
but it's all individual and
what i did i hugged this woman from
health protection agency and we cried
it was very emotional
and after testing anatoly he was testing
too
it was not any polonium at all
goodness i couldn't go to home almost
for three months because it was under a
police investigation
but when police said we've done and you
can go you can take this your house back
but actually i couldn't
everything was in this
messages
how much radioactivity
they could spot it
and if i want to go back to live in a
house i need to
disexterminate it
and when it was asking how much it would
cost to
make this house be safe
price was 300 000 pounds
and of course
i couldn't pay
and this was only way to keep this house
closed and it would be natural
discriminated
it took another two and a half years
to go back
to this house
do you live in the same house now
no i couldn't live in this house anymore
after that
before his death
tir alexander blamed anyone
when sasha is still alive and was two
suggestions first take a picture of him
i was against i didn't like to take this
picture and sasha was very strong in his
mind and he said we have to
and then it was
suggestion to write
his statement
and his statement he blamed directly
vladimir putin of killing him
and he said incredible words
now after 15 years it'd still be very
important he said
you might silent
one person
but
as a voice of crowd
around the world will stay in your earth
till end of your life and now in 15
years we can see
putin
might try to do anything to silent
people
but
not people became silent all around the
world
and
who in your opinion is behind his
poisoning
i tried every time based
on serious
facts and arguments i could be very
emotional i have all rights because my
husband
killed
murder brutal front of all this world by
radioactive material
but after investigation
after public inquiry when everything was
provided
we have
a very serious allegations
after public inquiry it was saying
andrea lugavoy and dmitry coughton
definitely
killed my husband alexandre littinianka
and this is very
highly likely
happened with the knowledge of vladimir
putin president of russia
and
former director of fsb nikolai patricio
who still be in a very high position
and this russia stayed behind of this
crime
recently we received a decision of
european court of human rights
and they proved exactly the same
they said
is this
russia stayed behind of this crime
where are you now in your battle for
justice
first of all we now
it's almost
almost months since we received this
decision
of course um
russia states they know we've never done
it
and
i just hope one day they will release
their own statement and their opinion
for what they
believed happened
all these 15 years i can't say
i pushed very hard it's all happened how
it's supposed to happen
i exhausted
all my legal
rights
we couldn't provide a proper justice
it was inquest and unquest became a
public inquiry we had this
court in europe but i believe one day we
will have a proper justice
people who committed this crime
need to be on a trial
what i promised to sasha i promised to
him if somebody want to listen
and he asked me please talking to them
please talking to people
say what happened to us
might it helped people to prevent
something to protect them i don't know
but i do what sasha asked me
and
because what i agreed to do
uh giving interview meeting people it
means you're always around
and
what i'm happy i gave him this life
and i feel sometimes i'm protecting by
him too
because my life was not miserable
for this last week
last 15 years
it was a lot of happiness
it was a chance to see how our son
became adult it was not easy it was very
difficult
but
it's exactly
what
why i'm doing this
they killed sasha physically
but he's still alive
[Music]
my heart is to disappear with
and i know that is if i arrested and
sent back to north korea
i just execute or prison camp